Yeah,
no,
I think we had to start from the fact,
you know,
somebody once said to me,
you're,
I didn't,
I didn't march in the sixties so that
men could sleep together.
And I was like,
well,
you know,
that's the right mack is byard Rustin
had that held down like the man who
planned the march on Washington was,
was gay,
was known to be gay,
um,
and,
and that was okay with Dr King and it
was okay with Julian bond and John Lewis
then.
And it's,
it's okay now.
I mean,
I only regrets it,
but by residents,
they still isn't with us planning,
planning,
planning marches.
So I think we have to start from the
premise that gay people are part of the
NAACP.
Gay people are part of the social
justice movement that gay,
black people in particular,
um,
you know,
live both of those identities as we all
live,
you know,
multiple identities.
You know,
the,
the Naacp for that reason has always
been quick to recognize,
uh,
you know,
across a whole range of issues that are
common interests of black people as
black people,
you know,
or multiple identities as black people
and gay people as gay people.
There are multiple shades of colors.
I mean,
for instance,
issues of police brutality,
employment discrimination,
hate crimes.
We've been there side by side,
fighting on again and again.
Uh,
we set a big victory.
The Matthew Shepard,
James Byrd,
bill at the NAACP,
but ads in Texas to promote and really
to beat up on then governor about to
become President Bush for his lack of
support 10 years ago.
And we're out there now in the
employment nondiscrimination act and
we're out there now in Uganda.
No,
I mean we,
we,
we hate the definitely because it's the
death penalty,
but we also,
uh,
you know,
we hate it all the more when you say
that,
that you want to make being a member of
a minority group,
any minority group,
the reason that you get the death
penalty and that's what they're trying
to do in Uganda,
they're trying to actually make being
gay,
uh,
a crime punishable by death.
The,
where there has been distanced recently
has been between religious communities
in general and the Movement for marriage
equality and the NAACP has a very
religious base and people who want to
see movement on that issue of people
wanting to feel like people want to see
more blacks in the Republican Party.
A need to invest in outreach,
need to really say,
you know,
what that constituency as a priority
and,
and I'm gonna,
you know,
make it my business to make sure that we
reach out to that consumer constituency
on their terms in the way that's most
effective.
That's what any good organizer does.
That's what I do for the issues that I'm
pushing the,
um,
with that said,
Julian Bond,
for instance,
our,
our past chair is very outspoken in
support.
Um,
I've let it be known that I personally
support marriage equality.
My brother,
the man who is closer to me than any man
on this planet,
uh,
my best friend since I was six years
old,
we started six months and,
and his mom celebrated mother's Day with
my mom and,
and his family lived with us off and on
for a third of my life.
Um,
is gay,
is HIV positive,
is a on again,
off again,
homeless.
I've,
I've spent many a lot of money trying to
keep them from being homeless,
but sometimes people just,
you know,
issues in their life that you,
that,
that no dollar can overcome.
Um,
so it's very personal for a lot of us I
guess is what I'm saying.
But we're a democratic organization at
the end of the day and that means that
we tend to be on the front edge of some
issues and we tend to lag behind on
others and we'd never get there until
consensus as bill.
And that's why I say to folks,
look,
if you'd want to see the naacp even more
active than we have been and we've been
active in California,
a folks there in California voted to
oppose prop eight and they,
and they rolled out all the stops to
oppose it.
The National Office signed onto the
lawsuit to invalidate probate because we
were able to get consensus on the
principle that I'm a simple majority
vote,
should not be able to trump a court's
finding of a fundamental right.
And that's a threat to whole range of
rights,
including the right to marry.
Um,
but also,
I mean,
you know,
the right to,
to,
uh,
be treated with respect in the workplace
and not discriminate against in the
workplace.
For instance.
Apparently now it can be put up to a
vote in California.
So,
um,
you know,
we,
we have been involved,
you know,
gay people who have been involved in the
naacp for a long time.
The Naacp has been supportive abroad
civil human rights agenda in this
country,
including,
uh,
rights for gay and lesbian people for a
long time.
Um,
and,
and we have many,
many of our most outspoken leaders are,
are very outspoken on the issue of
marriage equality and many are outspoken
against it.
And,
uh,
like any other democratic organization
and trade union,
what,
what have you,
it's being worked through.
And the way that one side wins or the
other is that they decide that,
that they want the membership of the
Naacp to be supportive of this one
particular part of the agenda more than
the other side does.
And,
and right now it seems to be a bit of a
tossup.